hey how's it going brahs is beautiful
welcome to finder it's pretty sweet
it came out last night Jesus Christ
there's a lot of hype about this game so
let's just put on our headphones turn up
the volume and see if this is worth the
hype fast pace fright the horror
attraction local amusement park is
getting ready to scare your socks off
with a new attraction based on the
unsolved mysteries of Freddy fazbear's
pizza so this is taking place at oh god
what the [ __ ] after everything has
happened what the [ __ ] is this thank you
everything fire so it look like they
strip down a lot of things which might
make sense I mean they did add some
stuff too I'm still very confused it's
just a lot to take in at once cuz you're
kind of used to the old format to it I
mean I don't feel scared at all not to
be like that
I know it's just starting but it kind of
feels like one of the fan made games to
be honest I kind of miss the flashlight
it was really fun to keep flicking that
[ __ ] I'm restarting the ventilation oh
my god it takes a lot of time to do that
let's just wanted to try it out I like
the mirror I guess I am
invisibility lady I guess I am Stephen
Hawking Mexican
really wow I did it I'm so proud of
myself
I know what's going in it and my Freddie
I'm gonna go I'm afraid II I'm gonna go
I'm a Freddy Krueger I'm afraid Freddy
will go inside your bed
that's a slipper isn't it slippery
Slough now it's a rat
ha ha ha Freddy the face beat yeah yeah
yeah yeah what's up players
what's up bommies I can't go here great
follow me who said that who said that
Freddy foods beer say you all right I'll
follow you baby
and now we're follow its his arrow so I
guess I can't
look like it sounds like some like a
corrupted Super Mario but it should some
[ __ ] yes yes yes
hey man ok I have some awesome news for
you tell me vigil house training is it
so these are like prehistoric I think
you're like training take more like
sauna room point something like that
nothing is showed up yet
Berenice ok is that the only one I know
that's the one
oh god he moved I don't know where he is
though maybe entered the vent it's
really [ __ ] hard to see I feel like
I'm gonna get jumpscared I have the
sensation in my butt it's clinging so
nice hey I think I just got gem scooped
hey I didn't die how about then or did I
ok
oh god he's behind me or am i him I mean
why am I not showing up in the mirror
better look away then heats that wheel
he's not real
hey buddy hey there penny just gonna
skin a chill here until 5 a.m. kid
Saturn I don't I don't trust you stop
looking at me like I stop it
stop it what are you doing buddy
why do you bolt Oh God uh just just hold
it oh god I saw him out I shine mob that
ain't cool man that ain't cool man
okay what was that what was that don't
think I didn't see it
I'm not gonna click anything until I
know I'm safe all right I'm not gonna
replay night you just cuz I don't know
kung fu [ __ ] I know kung foo so stay
the [ __ ] away how about that ha oh that
wait out stupid you're stupid go away I
see you I say I'm literally staring at
you I don't I don't understand what's
going on
I'm so so confused like what what's
going on maybe but this if you listen to
the audio log you would understand now
if I could hear a word that's going
through they put subtitles maybe follow
me alright well I shall follow you I am
my Bonnie or silver the ocean hey I fell
for this once before not gonna do what
again my bunny is over the sea my oh
that's pretty fast [ __ ] and thread I'm
Bonnie [ __ ] now what you gonna do bat
dammit not this [ __ ] again ah stop
I got damn it safe room where's my safe
room oh my god ventilate what are you
doing
quit EDD misdefinitie sphere
okay well I'm still gonna restart the
ventilation
what is going on I didn't understand it
the scary part about five finest
Freddy's is that they're coming towards
you not like hey I don't know I I don't
underst I know I select a new game no no
no no no no no no no no no no I don't
want to replay all that please please
please now please no I don't wanna oh my
god no are you [ __ ] kidding me
I discovered that I was so bored because
I had to replay everything again that I
just try to forget how to [ __ ] beat
it without having to play it and it
turns out if you just spam reboot
nothing happens great so good times I'm
just kind of hoping that something new
will happen once you beat night five you
know
all right price night for Liz Judy s is
it yes I don't I'm up a night for I
don't I don't understand anything at all
I know there's a guy and I know I have
to play the audio but I don't know I
don't know what that does maybe that
makes him go there hello good temps SAR
these whoo whoo howls who last ination
hula-hula nation well I saw him oh no we
better play some no he's gonna jump
scare me okay uh well you keep [ __ ]
with all my [ __ ] what [ __ ] just hop back
what what was that
I just got butt [ __ ] that's what it
seems like the less I try the more I
fail now wait the more I try the more I
fail that's it no you're not
okay yes you are then god dammit I don't
[ __ ] understand if TV press I need
your help
if you you probably know more than me
the next gross give me your help so I
can beat this game cuz I don't
understand [ __ ] I'm Swedish I'll blame
my swedishness how about that
they like feeling more press and I will
see you stay awesome bros what's
difference see in the morning foxy see
security guard said and with a friendly
pat on the head the security I left
foxy alone that night confused and
wondering